[Music]
and can't touch this I wanted to go for
two bars damn it
we never do two bars joke submitted by
protein parts Oh is there such thing
yeah Misha far there's protein
hemorrhoids [ __ ] first thank you and I
thought protein bars I thought like
protein powder just what's the
hemorrhoid again you have a great
imagination I know you should see every
time have to do it Vaughn dream there's
[ __ ] protein is recycle it with your
own body let's discuss there are we
talking about you sick freaks some third
world I want to know the article not
protein farts it was emitted by rather a
Scottish man is facing jail over a hip
touch you shouldn't be sexually
harassing ladies over there cuz that's
like execution [ __ ]
was he going like this like oh excuse me
you know yeah gently like just so that
people know that you're there and they
don't like turn around and smack you
excuse me was snow like that so arrest
me now
excuse me so this Scott is now facing a
three-year jail sentence over there in
Dubai : I mean if that's what their laws
are that's what their laws damn well
they're also reporting that he's going
to jail for drinking so it's not very
clear as mixed report yeah you thought
no places that serve alcohol direct all
family oh really
okay so this report here is saying that
Jamie who's 27 he said that he was
trying to avoid spilling his drink in
this crowded bar so they must have maybe
I'm wrong but there was something along
those lines of like it's not easy to
sell alcohol and Dubai or something or
it's not I don't know nothing ok let's
continue there's a general statement
you'll put that up yeah anybody Dubai
nobody to his awful out there let's go
oh I do know one thing
Dubai has vending machines that you
could buy gold from moi
like breaks right that's pretty cool how
rich are people out there mmm-hmm in
family right it has any
trying to break into them it's like a
vending machine a no-loss scare me hip
touch gets you arrested so so Jamie's
saying that he was trying to avoid
spilling his drink so then that's when
he kind of just slightly touched a man's
hip oh it was a man Wow and he says I'm
not gay
don't touch me there well bro they're
saying that initially it seemed like the
man was upset but not like super upset
it was just kind of like okay whatever
I'm so mad but not that not sat on the
table that's when the man that was
touched really seemed more aggravated
and then twenty to thirty minutes later
police arrived to the bar and arrested
James oh [ __ ] this is what happened you
know do things yeah I imagine this is
what happened right he's like dude dude
and then he's coming over with the drink
and he's like excuse me bro
hey yours oh no problem it's cool dude
dude dude and he goes back a row heap or
a Jeep or whatever what's the what's the
Arabic neighbor or the Arabic hey buddy
buddy okay honey Mohammed came Mohammed
hey hey buddy
weren't you doing something kind of gay
over there and it he's all like what I
saw you that was pretty gay Oh like his
friends are telling he's at the table
and his friends are like dude I saw that
gay action he's like I'm not gay I'm not
gay and then he got mad and then brawler
he's yeah yeah he's like police somebody
try to pull gay moves on me and then he
came in cuz gay is illegal over there
and that's what happened oh it's gay
illegal in dubious Dubai
there's a lot of things I don't know
about Dubai but what I do know about
Dubai is that one of the salt based
restaurants is there yeah and that [ __ ]
looks [ __ ] delicious that's the worst
[ __ ] to even know for this article why
so they're both spewing out but [ __ ]
that they want is
they're talking about [ __ ] like their
facts but they're like at the end I like
but I don't know but they are not sure
it's all pay there's a restaurant of
that no no before that he was like they
don't have they don't sell alcohol there
she well it's actually a bar I just need
you to collect yourself when you're
attacking people that's all we don't
give a [ __ ] whoa whoa hey hey I didn't
say I knew [ __ ] I started I started I
started this the world with I don't know
nothing it's right but let me tell you
something that is called loop taeseop
that is called possible case scenario
yes not worst case not best case
possible cases you get arrested for just
hip touching because it wasn't a conga
line he was arrested for public
indecency
and also for drinking alcohol oh so that
it wasn't at all for the hip touching
see that's what I'm saying like there's
a lot of like mixed reports here they're
like oh it's because of the hip touch
but then they're saying like the hip
touch led to the man getting angry and
then leading to Jaime getting locked up
for something that has nothing to do
with the hip touch I think that man we
eat that he had touches a very important
man that's what I was thinking
Paul ISM strength you're a good
detective because I was thinking the
same thing that means you're a genius
thank you
what if he was going what if he was
wearing white and the guy touched um and
then it was dirty
you're too cluttered or what if he was
just really drunk and heat what he
thought was just a light hip touch with
something he cupped his balls
yeah maybe one of these to his balls
people do when they're drugged
excuse me all right yes so they're
saying that Jamie Jamie worked as an
electrician in Afghanistan and was on a
two-day stopover in the United Arab
Emirates and then that's when this whole
thing happened he went to jail and he
has since lost his job and he has spent
almost $40,000 in expenses and legal
fees whoa
since the incident which happened in on
July 15 that sucks and he's still in the
country like they revoked
oh well I feel bad but then I don't go
bad so I feel bad because I'm doing it
from an American standpoint right like
wow that's kind of a bummer or whatever
but then if you're going to that country
and that's their laws and their rules no
sir what was their what's the laws in
the rules though so whatever he got in
trouble for I don't know if I didn't
even know you wouldn't have done that
well I don't think that he broke any
rules so I literally think he just he
messed with the wrong guy yeah wrong guy
that's all like it was Prince alibied
yes just stop at the [ __ ] name Prince
Ali Ababwa he just hit that is that
culturally correct um
Aladdin is that a folklore of the same
region I think that is Arabia Arabian
Persian I read this article saying that
Aladdin isn't really one specific he's
just a middle-eastern it's just a lot of
different stuff cuz based on the shape
of the building and his hat it looks
very Arabian yeah so I guess Disney
might have fun where that way but the
original original story of Aladdin
there is no there's an original original
yeah I like the book I just know he got
curly toe slippers and that's in the
comfortable spot curly oh is it like one
of those stories like Madame Butterfly
where some European person came up with
the story but they messed everything up
because it was intentional geo he knows
that what was it mother butterfly yeah I
guess it's something like how to spell
that [ __ ] mu D um
muffin apply back to Jamie so he was
locked up for five days in prison and
then he was released on bail what are
you in for they confiscated his passport
robbery what are you in for rape what
about you keep touch they're saying he
was expected to appear in court on a
Sunday but the court moved the date
without telling him
or his lawyer and then that led to a
sentence of 30 days imprisonment for
failing to present himself at the
hearing something Lucy was not even
telling anyone and then it's somebody
important that really dislikes this [ __ ]
there's no way he's a psycho typical
elected he probably stole one of the
girlfriends yeah or one maybe she didn't
even have nothing to do but then this
husband saw his wife checking him out
and he was like oh it's dad right yeah
cuz there's no way he's somebody's
pulling strings by the way that looks
like Waikiki looks pretty nice I would
like to go there I still want to go to
Dubai because everyone says Dubai wasn't
it I don't know I don't keep up with the
times
well if you do go to Dubai make sure
that you actually read out all the laws
because they're saying that it is kind
of scary this is another example of how
vulnerable tourists are to arrest and
detention in Dubai talked oh we don't
really do anything that's very like
dubious well this guy just touched it
yeah I don't know in the bars I don't I
don't really drink like that so and if
Gina could do it without anything
happened she had a local a local
shortener around Sears and she was with
the Prince or something make sure you
went to go visit some royalty fine I'll
bring Gino
so that's if we go to Dubai we have to
hang out with Dubai royalty that makes
it sound like she went there for sex
that's not true no one was thinking I
would even if she did lucky her [ __ ] she
went some cardio I cannot hate on people
that go out and have fun and get taken
care of because me and David were wined
and dined by a gay man that was very
wealthy and I felt objectified but at
this
same time he was great company and the
food was delicious if it was why are you
whoa why do you feel like you have to
get some stuff off your chest you want
to talk about it no we're not getting it
off our chest we're just saying but we
didn't even have sex that's the thing I
felt like I owed him a [ __ ] or
something yeah I just got why didn't i
cuz you know like prior to it like I
think I was a little bit preachy about
having self-respect [ __ ] all that [ __ ] I
did that for steak I wasn't talking
about that people do it for money I
literally did for a piece of steak yep
I'll do anything
arm candy for the day it was fantastic
hope you guys enjoyed that episode of JK
news make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here
[Music]